to start off with we recognize on the
committee the huge challenge that the
coronation presented golden orb was one
of the largest operations in the history
of the met and I think it is to their
credit that they kept everybody safe and
without major incidents
however we do have a series of questions
about the policing of protests at the
coronation and we've got the two panels
this morning at the first panel with the
Metropolitan Police and the National
Police Chiefs Council representative and
then in the second panel we're going to
hear from those who were arrested and
detained plus a lawyer with extensive
experience in the area so could I just
ask our first panel to introduce
themselves
um would you like to start good morning
chair thank you my name is Matt twist
I'm the assistant commissioner for met
operations
good morning chair Chris Noble Chief
Constable of Staffordshire police but
for the purposes of this hearing at
least I'm also the national policing
lead around the policing protest thank
you very much now um we are quite short
on time so and we've got quite a lot of
members who want to ask questions so if
you could be brief in your answers that
would be helpful and if I could just
implore members of the committee to be
fairly succinct as well in their
questioning that would be good could I
could I just start
um uh with the first question which is
uh did the Metropolitan Police feel
under any political pressure the police
the coronation in a certain way
no
no okay not at all I think as as is the
case with any policing operation the
first thing to say is that we would
rigorously guard our operational
Independence which is critically
important
um and we police the laws as they are
set without fear or favor and that is
has always been the case and what is
clear in the case of protest is that
there are strongly held and differing
views
um in public on social media and across
politics actually as to what is right
and what isn't right
so our objective is very much to police
the laws as they are set without fear or
favor and I was grateful to you chair at
the start for highlighting just how it
enormous the operation was
um the correlation of his majesty King
Charles and queen Camilla
was a historic moment of huge National
significance and we're proud to have
successfully ensured it was delivered
safely and in a secure way despite the
most challenging fast-moving and complex
policing picture we've ever encountered
for a national celebration right thank
you can I just ask you then were you
surprised that the the home office
police Powers unit wrote to
organizations like Republic on the 27th
of April setting out the new Provisions
within the public order act which would
use to come into Force were you
surprised by that that wasn't something
I was familiar with at the time I think
Chris might have
um some knowledge of the of the letter I
don't think it's completely unusual what
happened before in other cases then yeah
chair just just to help again we weren't
aware of it from a policing point of
view so that the detail the the motive
ultimately is one for home office and
home office officials to speak to but
the pcsc ACT again primarily because of
the compressed time between royal ascent
and commencement my understanding is
that letters were sent out previously
for that previous piece of legislation
sorry on that piece of legislation they
were sent out previously you're saying
on the pcsc ACT
between royal ascent and commencement
maybe 14 days for one element of that
legislation to come into place so I
believe letters were sent out because of
that compressed time scale I think
that's been replicated in this occasion
for the public order act right
so as I said I'm not familiar with the
letters and I think that that's
something that would have to be
addressed to the home office right when
I asked the minister about it he he kind
of said well he hadn't signed the letter
he didn't seem to know very much about
it either
so on that point I can't help any
further I'm afraid okay
okay Jerry now thank you chair just
quickly can I ask you
uh
some commissioner twist why do you think
it was reported in the newspapers that a
senior met a senior met Source said that
pressure political pressure had come
from above
so
um honestly I have no idea in that I
can't comment on Anonymous sources that
were reported in the newspapers without
any detail from my point of view I felt
under no pressure politically I felt
pressure to deliver a safe and secure
operation but that was because of the
fact it was a once in a lifetime event
for so many people and there would be
hundreds of thousands of people in
London to celebrate it and also and
importantly this was the biggest
protection operation we have ever run
there were 312 protected people that we
managed to get in and out of the Abbey
and across the footprint in about 90
minutes so the stakes were enormously
high so I absolutely felt pressure to
deliver a safe and secure operation but
that wasn't political pressure that was
the pressure to do a good job
but you're also take into account the
fact that the police have a duty under
Section 6 of The Human Rights Act to
facilitate protest
of course so and I have seen reporting
which is completely erroneous and false
that suggests that all protest was
prohibited or banned or in some way
constrained that simply isn't the case
we're very familiar with our duties
around dealing with protests both
positive duties under the Human Rights
Act and negative duties and balancing
the rights of people who wish to protest
with those impacted by the protest is
part of the day-to-day job of policing
in London I think it's fair to say that
in just in the last 12 months we've
dealt with something like 4 000 events
and 500 of them are protest specific
and even it's a point that's worth
noting as well since the the legislation
that we're talking about was enacted and
all the same was given there's been 67
protest events in London the only time
the new legislation has been used was
the one-off occasion we're talking about
here today
not there about the balance fitting the
balance right
um you'll be aware that the European
convention on human rights provides that
protests can be limited in order to
protect the rights of others but any
restriction of that right is only lawful
if it's both proportionate and necessary
under article 10 and article 11. so do
you accept that when it comes to the
balance the scales are actually weighed
in favor of protecting the right to
protest rather than equally balanced and
that was the conclusion of my committee
when we looked at uh part three of the
police crime Center single courts bill
which was the precursor of the public
order Act so of course we're really
familiar with the and part of the
complexity of this area of law is that
there are a number of both primary and
secondary or legal instruments that play
there's the Human Rights Act and then
there's case law and all of the time the
law was being interpreted by the courts
and most recently in the case Supreme
Court case in Ziegler which set out the
conditions that we might need to
consider as part of this but you're
absolutely right of course the Articles
9 10 11 of the European convention do
form the basis of an individual's right
to participate in peaceful protest and
we fully respect that but it's also as
as you've said and I agree with this is
a qualified right
and we are continually balancing the
rights of those who seek to protest with
those who are impacted by it and what we
have seen latterly
is where there's a sort of fine line
between what is peaceful protest and
then what is straying into illegal
activity as we've seen in the sort of
latter part of last year and the start
of this year and where those right the
shifting of those scales sort of takes
place where crime is being committed
then obviously we need to have intervene
much more quickly can I put it to you
that the language of balancing which is
used frequently by police officers and
police policing bodies is not always
helpful because if you view protest as
inherently problematic and inconvenient
rather than as a necessary and important
element of a free Society bounce will
almost always fall on the side of
maintaining order and preventing crime
whereas the starting position should
always be that peaceful protests should
not be restricted and should be
facilitated so far as possible and I I
agree with that and the evidence I
believe would show that that's what we
do
getting the balance right between the
qualified rights of protesters and the
impact is is difficult but and protest
is by its nature designed to get
attention we understand that
um but I'm very clear that there's a
strong presumption in favor of the right
to protest and that's important in a
Democratic Society but where that Strays
into crime then obviously the police
will inact deal with the laws as we find
them but this is something we are very
familiar with and we understand the sort
of Human Rights position Constable Noble
do you want to add anything on that yeah
just a couple of points I think there
might be some debate amongst articles 8
9 10 and 11 where a hierarchy exists and
clearly from a policing point of view
articles two and three are pretty
fundamental so very often in a public
order event or protests are involved
there can be matters of Public Safety
come to the fore which clearly then need
to be effectively dealt with but just to
support Matt you know policing is not
anti-protest we've got positive and
negative obligations under human rights
legislation my experience in a different
jurisdiction is actually fundamentally
it is a good thing for society in terms
of being able to protest in a peaceful
but also a reasonable way and I think a
lot of the things that we will probably
discuss today or have debates about are
where that Tipping Point is reached
whether we like to call it a balancer or
not because that's the language of the
courts uh where that Tipping Point is
reached in terms of when it becomes
unreasonable and then policing without
any great desire to do so has to
intervene and ultimately allocate
resource that they would much rather
allocate in other parts of the policing
environment so there is no presumption
against protests it's actually quite the
opposite
can you tell us do all police officers
receive ongoing training on their human
rights obligations
um so in terms of the sort of training
environment for policing there's an
initial input at initial training in
terms of Human Rights obligations that
there's a model around decision making
and placing called the national
decision-making model which has it as at
its core key tests around human right
obligations that will be reinforced on
an ongoing basis whenever new
legislation is introduced whenever we
move into the world of public order and
Public Safety
um there are really quite strict initial
courses to be attended there's
re-accreditation there's quarterly CPD
for the most senior commanders there's
regular CPD for more Junior and
specialist commanders and then there
will be accessed both pre-juring and
post-event to specialist lawyers again
around human rights obligations to test
the policing operation before during and
after and then clearly an appropriately
significant scrutiny whether it be from
committees like this iopc police and
crime Commissioners and indeed other
bodies who have a real interest in
protest as well thank you that's Simon
fell thank you thank you um
Chief Constable um
I just wonder whether you could take us
through
um how police forces across the country
prepare
um when a new act like the the public
order Act is brought in
terms of the preparation for that new
legislation Landing
um it can be challenging um you know
we've had sort of moving Parts recently
in terms of legislation but to be very
transparent from a policing point if you
are asked off the home office was give
us current legislation give us
legislation which is fit for the
challenges that we're facing today and
that is capable of being enforced so a
significant amount of the changes in
legislation whilst policing doesn't set
the law it's made it very clear where
they have identified some gaps or some
challenges But ultimately the making of
the law is a matter for Parliament as is
the timing of that law actually
commencing
um so on this occasion I think Royal
assent was granted on the 2nd of May at
about half two in the afternoon
um commenced at midnight technically on
the 3rd of May within 10 hours then we
have briefing documents across the
country the chief constables to our gold
commanders which are our most senior
public order commanders and that was
cascaded down as well and Matt might
want to speak about how that happened
within London but putting that
information in officers hands what we
couldn't do was preempt exactly what
would come out of the legislation we
weren't going to do anybody's job for
them we didn't want to put a version out
in advance which would have to be
amended so whilst timing was compressed
we'd had discussions in advance about
how we would do that and get the
information to the hands of people who
need it so and from a London perspective
of course we got the correspondence from
the mpcc and the college guidance
um at the time shown this was circulated
to all public order commanders within
the met at all levels as well as our
public order training skills staff and
our tactical advisors on the same day
there was a specific briefing by the
silver Commando and one of our most
experienced officers from the Strategic
Training unit who trains public order
officers for the command team who are
taking place in operation golden orb and
some of the bronzes within that command
team then placed constraints on the use
of that legislation that it would only
be used if they were notified and
consultant in advance so whilst it was
those short notice between the operation
and the timing of it is a matter for
Parliament we believe we were in good
shape in terms of the briefing and
officers knew what they had to do
thank you and and so in the case of gold
and all we we know um you'll be hearing
from from some of the other Witnesses
later on this but you've been in
communication with some of the protest
groups who are planning to attend
um obviously this is something new for
you to to understand how to implement
this legislation how to use it
appropriately it's also something new
for them
could you take us through some of the
detail in those Communications in that
dialogue so what would that look like
you if do that if they have questions do
they come back to you do you just point
them at the bill
I think in the broader sense
um it always works best when groups are
looking to protest engage with the
police and this is something that's been
going on there for many years where we
have a protest liaison team Gateway team
people that want to conduct large
protests in London will make contact
with that team and that is not for us in
any way to constrain what they want to
do but we can provide advice we can
provide
um be clear on what the responsibilities
of organizers might be and this is a
tried and tested process for many many
protest groups now that will engage with
our Gateway team who will then get
notified about what they want to do and
what that helps with is it helps us
provide a proportionate policing
response which at times may be nothing
at all depending on what the matters are
in hand there are some groups who don't
engage at all which makes things much
more challenging both in resourcing
terms
um and in terms of what their intentions
are and what where they might go so
groups like animal Rebellion or just
stop oil do not engage despite
attempts for us to do that therefore
which means it leads to Greater
abstractions from local policing frankly
as we have to continually manage an
unknown sort of risk
in terms of this case the if we're
talking about the public protest
um not my king then they did engage with
the protest liaison teams in advance
um via multiple means in terms of
letters earlier in the year and then
there was further correspondence in the
run-up I don't know whether there was
specific engagement on the point of the
new legislation
because I suppose that's what I'm trying
to get to because yeah at the nub of
this and we'll find out some of my
colleagues will pick up on this later
but
you know there were straps used to hold
placards together which were interpreted
as as potentially being potentially used
for your devices for locking on
um and I'm just trying to understand
whether there would be a dialogue around
that sort of granularity around whether
a strap in the back of a van might be
considered
as something that would be of concern to
you or whether it is just pointing
towards legislation and saying you need
to understand this yourselves
now I think I think our view our start
point was always to try and be as
helpful as we could be
um I don't know whether or not a
discussion was had about any such straps
in advance of the combination and and
I've seen various descriptions of what
those straps are but we can touch on
that if if needed but um I I don't know
if that actual discussion was had in
advance
thank you
thank you um moving on now to Alison
thulis thank you very much and I want to
pick up I where time left off and talk
about the kinds of objects that would be
covered uh by the new offense of being
equipped to look on what's your
understanding of that
so I think it's contextual I think in
terms of you know we need to look at
in terms of implementing law you need to
look at what the person's intent might
be you need to look at what the object
is and then meet that with an intent or
a likelihood of doing it because clearly
something like a D Lock could be used to
lock on
could also be used to secure your
bicycle precisely that's the point you
can just stop oil t-shirts I'm cycling
along the road
where's the context there and how would
you interpret that so again I mean it's
a hypothetical but my point was exactly
that in the a a seemingly innocent item
could in the right context be something
that would be considered to be going
equipped for locking on what we would do
is we would base this on intelligence we
would base this on actions we were based
this on the group and clearly at the
time what we were talking about if we
draw this back to Golden all was a
situation where we had very clear
intelligence that was deeply concerning
sufficiently so that we ended up
briefing the Home Secretary and the
mayor late at night on the Friday and we
briefed senior stakeholders and partners
late on the Friday and early on the
Saturday that there was a concerted
attempt there was going to be a
concerted attempt to disrupt the
coronation procession
and the officers were asked to be
extremely Vigilant and extremely
proactive in dealing with this so in the
wider threat context that would have
played into some of the decision making
I think
but there's no history of Republic ever
having locked on yet their members were
arrested um and presumably items that
were securing the placards were taken by
your officers so we don't know that they
were securing placards that's what been
that was what was said the items
themselves were in sort of clear plastic
bags which were sealed so they hadn't
been used for that purpose as far as we
could see in the van but that's right
Officer officers have to make a
difficult Judgment at the time in the
moment based on what they're faced with
and based on the information they have
they have to form reasonable grounds for
an arrest and as the committee will know
reasonable ground is actually quite a
low threshold and is much lower than
actually where you would need grounds to
meet the evidential test to charge and
the public interest test to charge so
what was found was 12 heavy duty
material straps the combination locks on
them which the officers were told were
for securing placards but at the time
the officers were operating in a threat
environment where they believed taking
into account the time the location
um proximity to the route and what they
had in front of them those officers
believe that those could be items that
could be used for locking on and that
was why the arrest was made
you're looking more widely at such an
item as a luggage strap there must be
thousands of people that go through
Central London a video with a luggage
strap
how reasonable is it to assume that that
kind of thing is a threat so I think
that takes it straight back to the
context in the it was both in terms of
the intelligence we had the once in a
lifetime once in a generation event the
proximity to the event itself and to
where we thought the threat was likely
to manifest itself
um and the time there wasn't much time
between these officers stopping the van
um and the actual ceremonials or
procession taking place
so you're quite right these items on
their own in Heathrow Airport are not
going to be something that might cause
concern if someone was walking around
with 12 of them there may be some
questions asked
um but this isn't something you need
more than just the item I think the
officers would need to show that there's
some sort of intent or intelligence that
would lead us to believe
um in the context that these could be
items that we use for locking on but
this is this vagueness is in legislation
now and so going forward away from
something like the coronation which is a
bigger one-off event that could then be
used at any point at any time to
question somebody's ability to have
something like idlock or a luggage stop
or a cable ties or anything of that kind
couldn't it I think it's then for the
officers to show that they've acted both
proportionately and reasonably it's then
to show that if somebody is arrested at
the sort of threshold of reasonable
suspicion to then meet that evidential
threshold is you know a completely
different step and then if you get to
that evidential threshold and they've
delete the CPS
um or the police believe there is
sufficient to charge
then the courts will interpret that and
we'll look at the circumstances at the
moment you're right there is no case law
on this but my point is that officers
still need to act proportionately and
reasonably
and that their actions need to be
necessed necessary in all of the
circumstances so I think the Saturday
that we're talking about whilst it was
the first time this legislation was used
is also
I don't think legislation that we're
going to be see used day in day out or
even week in week out on the basis that
since it was passed there have been 67
actually 68 now other demonstrations
that have taken place and we have not
used this legislation on any of them
can you tell me what it means to attach
for the purposes of working on
so from for me locking on would be to
secure yourself to something else we'd
have to take the ordinary dictionary
definition
yeah but to attach specifically
as I said I don't have the definitions
does that cover
um locking yourself to somebody else
pulling yourself to somebody else
my view on this is I would I would sort
of look at a common sense definition in
terms of what you know securing yourself
to someone else I don't know Chris may
know a national sort of approach on this
I think probably the example I would
give because it's one I shared with it
with the bill scrutiny committee is at
the at the G7 event there was a scenario
that policing encountered
um were they had information that
individuals would be coming down to
create devices and indeed potentially
lock the lock onto the proof test
um and indeed at one point in time I
think they were stopped on the road in
various bamboo pools and other things
were discovered policing essentially had
to let that run until eventually it
became a substantive offense and then
they had the intervene and ultimately
impacted much more in the rights of
other people as well so from an
operational perspective even though this
might be very rarely used and there is a
degree of breadth in the framing offer
absolutely
um you could have the scenario where
someone's sitting down on a road
potentially committing an offense but
people walking towards them with bicycle
locks very clear exactly what was going
on and police May well not have had the
ability to interview
so I I think there are challenges around
interpretation I can see the concerns
about is this too broadly framed what I
would say is the imagination to protest
groups are also very broadly framed and
from a policing point of view if the law
is too narrow it can essentially mean
that that's much more easily
circumvented for individuals looking to
be unreasonable in their protest and
cause serious disruption but it has to
be handled carefully
understand that the maximum penalty for
locking on is a fine is detaining people
appropriate
so I think that's a that's a matter for
parliament in terms of where the powers
of arrest are drawn
um and the matter for the cause
um
this offense may not sit in isolation as
well because where we have seen is this
the going equipped offense obviously
would but as Chris has alluded to there
may well be other offenses that come
into play as well in those circumstances
potentially causing a statutory public
nuisance under Section 78
um so this is a preventative measure
where at the moment as Chris has alluded
to
there wasn't the power to stop people
who we had intelligence that were going
to lock on until they did so and that
then led to a much greater disruption of
other people's rights because it then
takes a long time to remove somebody who
is locked on so this enables us to have
that proactive power to prevent that in
the right circumstances
but in certain circumstances there had
to be a referral to bronze command in
terms of the public order
um if there was going to be use of that
did that happen in this particular case
then can you assure us that bronze
command were told
the the these people are going to be
detained so this this isn't policy this
is and I'll answer the question this
isn't policy this is something that we
did given the short notice and that we
weren't sure that every inspector every
Sergeant would have fully understood it
it was a constraint that we put on for
this one operation and in terms of the
specific question yes the bronze
Commander for the sector was notified
um of the arrest under this um did that
bronze Commander have the information
about the engagement with Republic did
they know what had been agreed and what
was said and I don't know off the top of
my head my expectation would be that yes
um that the whole command team would
have been alert to
um engagement that had been taking place
with the public because we would have
been notified of that protest so we
would have been expecting it
um but I don't know what was in her mind
at the time
you don't know what was in their mind I
don't well I don't know um in terms of I
can't put myself whilst my expectation
is that the bronze was aware of the um
today to explain what's happening but
you don't actually seem to know what who
knew what oh I suppose you used to have
found that out but okay Tim Lawton
thank you chair
um assistant commissioner can I just be
clear you've said that the the placards
that were uh from the Republic Group
which when the component parts or
whatever
there were luggage straps with
combination locks with them
in your experience have you seen other
placards that have been attached using
luggage straps with combination locks
so in my experience no but that doesn't
mean that hasn't happened
unusual but this answered it but for me
I would have been it would have been
unusual because normally we see the
placards that are attached using
um cable ties or string or rope or
something like that I mean these are
heavy duty things with and it's the
combination lock is part of them so it
sort of links together and then there's
a combination on it so it would have
been unusual which I think is why
um it would have allowed suspicion of
the officers it usually use a
combination lock to stop
thank you
the proceeding is currently suspended
right we're now back in session
to be clear they would just stop oil
protesters who tried to undermine the
activities of this committee with our
Witnesses today uh assistant
commissioner just back to the use of
combination logs and my understanding
use a combination lock to stop somebody
getting into something or or undoing
something to get into a something it's
unusual to lose them but use them in
order to assemble a placard or any other
bits of wood just seems a bit odd does
it not so so I think that's how
um you could read that yes and I suspect
that that was part of the grounds that
were formed that this was unusual and
just back to the early conversation
about somebody having a D Lock where a
defense would be well it's to secure my
bicycle but if somebody is at a
demonstration without their bicycle
presumably they would have left that D
lock on the bicycle in order to secure
it so it's unusual to be carrying a D
lock without your bicycle one one would
have thought so thank you can I just the
standard question everyone asks is ahead
of the coronation the Met tweet it and I
quote that it's tolerance for any
disruption whether through protest or
otherwise would be low and that it would
deal robustly with anyone intent on
undermining this celebration so
notwithstanding the fact that this was
the largest event on the ever the
largest assembly of of
world leaders that was there how did you
approach the policing of this event
differently to to justify that statement
and and cut sort of warning effectively
yeah so so I think what's important is
the difference between protest and
disruption
and what we were talking about there and
we said that our tolerance of disruption
would be low but to be clear it wasn't
zero we did say that we would have zero
tolerance of any breaches of safety or
security and that was part of the um
driven by the fact we had 312 protected
people and the largest Security
operation we'd ever run
what's clear is on the day some
disruption did happen in the the tens of
thousands of people that came to
um watch the coronation and peacefully
enjoy a once in a lifetime event
there were large numbers of
um not my king and other protest groups
that were there shouting
um making a noise and whilst they were
roundly booed by the crowd at different
points that to me points to officers
striking the right balance in that we
managed to allow or for large large
groups of protesters were able to be in
the crowd and make with very large signs
with very large banners
um and peacefully coexist with the
overwhelming majority of people who'd
come to enjoy the celebration on that
point can you just finally
a child there was a big recognized
organized group of protesters in
Trafalgar Square
um I gather and then various other
groups roughly I mean whether just
they're scattered all over the place in
one group in Trivago Square were there
several groups that were recognized and
it was all fine just how many protesters
roughly were there and where where were
they so there were several hundred in in
and around Trafalgar Square that were
originally sort of near to the corner
where the um procession was going to
turn and at one point they moved away
and then came back again we found and
this is where I sort of differentiate
there were other people who were
protesting at various points in very
small numbers across the route
and then we move into those who we were
considering we're going to present a
criminal threat to the procession so in
this case the just stop oil activists
who we stopped both in Whitehall and at
the bottom of Duke of York's steps where
a large number of them were present and
we had intelligence and we honestly
believe that those people were going to
seek to disrupt the coronation
procession so in my thinking at that
point this was a conspiracy to commit
public nuisance at the very least and so
we dealt with those from a criminal lens
not a protest lens in terms of the
Republic protesters who were
legitimately in a group into Fargo
Square there was no problem none of
those were were arrested not the ones
that were there as far as far as of
aware
thank you James Daly thank you very much
chair um just for context
um
can you tell us how many people were in
central London that day roughly in terms
of numbers
it's hundreds of thousands
um in terms of the footprint itself and
we the numbers were constrained just
through the organizers to maintain
Public Safety but across the whole
footprint
um there would have been hundreds of
thousands of people in central London
the exact numbers I don't know
of course you've given us an idea of
that and obviously when you were
policing any number of people or num
that size of population then the Safety
and Security of that of those people and
everyone else in the area where they are
is Paramount
of course and it doesn't matter what
your background is or what you're doing
you don't differentiate on that the
Safety and Security of people is what is
that the core of the policing I think
this touches on the um human rights
point that Chris referenced earlier so
there is a hierarchy in the article too
in terms of our duties under right to
life which is more important than some
of the other rights absolutely so of
course Public Safety
um and also the security of those people
that we are protecting is critical okay
you gave evidence to say that the Home
Secretary and the London mayor was
briefed just give us an idea of what the
intelligence was that you passed on to
them as long as it's not confident I
don't know whether it's comfy yeah or
not but so clearly I can't go into the
details of intelligence but what I can
say was that we were during the course
of the Friday the 5th and into
um a Saturday on the evening of the
Friday I was significant I was concerned
enough that the Home Secretary was
briefed late in the evening as was the
London mayor on the growing intelligence
picture and then subsequent ministerial
briefings happened in the morning
we were absolutely concerned that there
were people who overnight were seeking
to deface and spray historic monuments
we were concerned there were people who
were going to incur onto the route we
were concerned there were people that
were seeking to disrupt a coronation
through
um loud noise the use of rape alarms has
been previously mentioned
um and the intelligence that we had was
real and the threat that we had that we
believed at that time was sufficiently
serious that we needed to brief those
key key sort of ministers tell us the
relationships when we started speaking
we talked about that primary Duty
for the safety of both people and in
this in this circumstance horses and
other animals that were part of the
coronation could you tell us the link
please between the intelligence and that
duty to protect people who were there in
central London that day of course we
were deeply concerned that um in the
event of people incurring onto the route
and members may have seen the conditions
of the horses were tricky enough as it
was with the rain and everything else
there was a very real risk that had
people incurred onto the route or had
they played sort of sudden loud
Amplified music that could have
literally scared the horses which could
have led to
um significant safety risk and
potentially Serious injury okay on the
day how many people were arrested in
total for activity related to the
coronation in total 52 out of 64 arrests
and some of them were
sort of as you say not linked they were
sort of picked up on
um on the footprint having been wanted
for other matters as an example
um so in terms of the
um we're going to hear from a
representative of republic
um it appears from The Briefing that
I've seen from Sir Mark role though she
said the the Met statement on this that
the position
um that the Met take is that the rest of
the six people was lawful do I
understand that correctly that may be
challenged in the courtly so it may be
challenged through civil proceedings
maybe challenge through all sorts of
means in terms of the position of the
mat is it that those arrests were lawful
yes and could you just I'm not asking
you to repeat but just exactly again say
why the Mets say those arrests were
lawful
because at that moment those officers
formed reasonable grounds to believe
that the people they had detained were
committing that offense and it's for
those officers and the state taking into
account the overall intelligence picture
the briefings they had
um to justify why those reasonable
grounds were formed
um but from what I've seen those my
belief and we've touched on the
difference between reasonable grounds to
suspect and the evidential threshold
needed to charge and to prove
um but I believe they're lawful
and so the perhaps if you could
develop this thing I mean the point has
been made to I think that why should
people be put into a custody if they are
being arrested for an offense where
there is not a custodial sentence at the
end of it I mean perhaps if you confirm
to it there are many many offenses and
many many occasions where people are
arrested for offenses where they are not
going to be receive a custodial sentence
even if they are charged with it but
they are taken into a custodial
environment to allow for investigation
of the circumstances of the arrest is
that correct that's quite right yes
I think if I may I mean I've got some
more detail on the arrests that may help
the committee thank you so I mentioned
64 in total across the weekend 52 will
link to activists or potential direct
action protest and these included
proactive arrests to preventive breach
of the peace and cause public nuisance
we found a group of people in possession
of white paint and plastic bottles
wearing high-vis jackets that could
easily have been construed as stewarding
jackets but had animal Rising logo on
the sleeves and these were arrested for
going to cryptical to criminal damage we
had intelligence in relation to just
stop oil intending to disrupt A
procession which resulted in the
proactive identification of groups on
the Maryland at Whitehall which resulted
in 23 arrests
eight of us were made for other offenses
including possession of offensive weapon
drugs breaching a sexual harm prevention
order
and our life facial recognition
deployment at three locations led to two
arrests one for one suspect was wanted
for breaching a sexual offense
prevention order where the index offense
was raped and the other was for going
equipped to steal
I think my last question James yeah if
it were the case that the map position
as I say the Mets position in respect of
this can be challenged with all sorts of
legal means and that matter for the the
people involved in that but if these
arrests were lawful if the behavior from
the police's perspective was was
absolutely correct why apologize
so I think we have what we haven't said
is an apology what I said was that we
regret that those that were detained and
subsequently no further action was taken
we regret that they missed the
opportunity to protest and that's just a
human thing to do it's not I don't we
don't want to get into the sort of
dancing on pinheads about will you
apologize won't you I believe that the
the arrest was lawful but of course once
we've conducted further investigation
and inquiries and we found out more
details of the engagement that had taken
place and we've looked at all of the
circumstances taken together it's quite
a I think quite a human thing to do so
yeah we regret that they missed their
opportunity to protest but what was also
very clear is that many hundreds didn't
miss that opportunity and were continued
on with that protest
which is quite contrary to some of the
reporting we've seen that all protest
was banned which clearly wasn't the case
thank you very much thank you Carolyn
Harris thank you
overall it was a an excellent day and
the police did a really good job but
this this incident has probably been a
big takeaway for a lot of people and as
much what was otherwise an excellent day
what would you have done
respectively what could you have done
differently
to have stopped this happening
so as always with any big event there's
going to be a full operational debrief
which we always do and we always look to
improve my initial sort of takeaway from
this would be had we been better able to
connect those officers that were making
the arrests and sort of forming their
reasonable grounds with the protests
liaison teams who were also deployed but
Elsewhere on the footprint
that may And I stress may have led to a
different outcome however what's also
very clear is that even if the protest
liaison teams had confirmed that they
had been engagement there had been
engagement with those individuals
that doesn't mean that a rest is
impossible because clearly people engage
and they don't tell us the truth and
purely people engage with um Ultra with
other nefarious motives in mind
um to give you a sense of the scale
though as to why that was difficult and
why we will look at and see how we can
do better on the day itself the policing
operation was split across nine
Geographic sectors with additional
functional commands dealing with things
like protection or traffic or security
of firearms we had 51 active radio
channels across nine sectors and that's
not including the protection channels
which added another 80 or so to it so in
the context of a fast-moving environment
in the context of a very high threat as
we saw it I can see why that didn't
happen but in terms of our debrief point
I think that would be one of the things
that I would focus on this will go
through Hydro process presumably and
in terms of the police officers involved
were they offers their list were they
nervous of the fact that it was such a
high profile event and they didn't want
to be seen be doing something which
wasn't
overly precocious
so I don't know if that's the case I
mean everybody knew the significance of
the event and officers were briefed as
to the intelligence and we had put in
place measures where the bronze
Commander would be briefed if we were
going to use the specific legislation
um we all knew the importance of the
Safety and Security that we've touched
on already because that was embossed
ensuring that those that wish to
peacefully protest could do so
um so I don't I don't think overzealous
is the right word I think of course we
were cautious but in the context of a
the larger Security operation we've ever
run the once in a generation once in a
lifetime event
um and no second chances to get it right
thank you very much um Madam chair
um first of all uh again my old
congratulations for how the operations
were on on the day uh and the
preparations for them as well
um
would I be correct in saying that uh the
reasonable
sorry no the reasonable grounds
um for believing that a person's arrest
uh being necessary uh and and that
threshold being met for the 52 that you
uh you personally the police uh in their
judgment decided when necessary on the
day could potentially include for the
fact that other members of the public uh
the members of the forces parading the
procession
could have come to harm
so
I think that's part of the overall
context I don't think that's part of the
reasonable ground itself I think there's
that could link to the necessity test
um but I think for me the reasonable
ground is based on what the officers see
the individuals doing but obviously
taking into account The Wider context
that we do if a consequence of a
potential disruptive Act is that others
could come to harm would the police be
Duty bound to take action if the if the
individual was committing an offense and
there was a power attached to it then
yes we would we would absolutely if one
of the things that you would consider in
terms of the necessity to make an arrest
would be the um you know harm to others
or the continuing harm to others but you
you just said if there is if a person is
committing an offense I think police can
make an arrest if they believe that
there might be a risk that offense might
be committed a that is also true right
so
um as I was walking into Parliament this
morning I was walking across Westminster
bridge and these people who were sat
behind you just a few moments ago were
walking very slowly and there was an
enormous amount of traffic behind
potentially with ambulances and being
prevented from getting to people
who might have needed
help quickly
would it not be in the police's judgment
in those circumstances that harm could
come to people
I can I can help with that specifically
so this was a just stop oil protest on
Westminster Bridge it started at 08 42
hours when they started marching towards
Parliament our first public order
officers were there at 0846 our first
Commander was there at 0851 conditions
were imposed on that group at 0856 and
they moved off the road
whilst we've been sat here in the
committee uh 0957 the same group moved
onto Parliament Square breaching those
conditions and officers started an
engagement process with a view to moving
to enforcement because I've been sat
here I don't know what the outcome of
that is but in terms of 14 minutes from
start to conditions being posed on the
road clear
um I think that's quite a good
performance this morning
okay thank you hey Anderson thank you
chair uh and thank you assistant
commissioner for coming here today and
like Marco I think he did a great job on
the day so thank you for that and a big
thank you to your officers but the more
cynical uh monsters and I'm not cynical
by the way
the more cynical amongsters may think
that you just turn up on this tables it
was a special occasion a big occasion
and did a really really good job uh what
can you say to the public and to this
committee to say that's not the case
that we take this very seriously and we
will we will um we will do this on a
more regular basis now in London because
like Marco said earlier we see these
protests almost on a daily basis and I
think the public and some of us have
lost a little bit of confidence but we
sort of regain that during the
coronation
thank you the I think as we touched on
that start getting the balance right
between qualified rights of protesters
and the impact they have is difficult
um particularly where they're using
disruptive tactics if I can reassure you
though in terms of the just stop oil
activity that we've seen in the
pre-Christmas period where we were
dealing principally with conspiracies to
block the motorway or people sitting
down in the road
we made 754 arrests those are all now
progressing through the criminal justice
system or most of them are but that was
an abstraction of twelve thousand five
hundred officer shifts which still
continues and those are people
abstracted from community policing since
the just double action that started a
few weeks ago this is their 12 weeks of
action so far we've seen 56 slow marches
we've imposed section 12 public order
conditions on 40 of those and that's led
to 29 arrests because in the main the
use of conditioning has worked
but so far because this is bigger and
more disparate that's already used over
9 300 officer shifts
so I think the community are right to be
concerned in terms of
um the amount of time and effort that
we're spending him to deal with
disruptive protests but also I think
members of the committee should be
reassured that we have a good
operational plan and as is evident from
this morning's activity we are dealing
robustly where people are just
effectively hell-bent on causing
disruption to the overwhelming majority
of others going about their lawful
business
next year I'm going to return to Joanna
Cherry for a short question thanks I'm a
bit troubled by the statement you made
uh Mr Twister the the fact that you were
booed by the crowd when you were
arresting people suggested that you'd
got the balance right
can you expand upon that no it's the
other way around
um the crowds were booing the protesters
okay and when when officers sorry you're
absolutely right forgive me that's my
sloppy question my question is this Are
you seriously suggesting as a senior
police officer that the fact that the
protesters were being booed by other
people
and then you went ahead and arrest them
the fact that they were being booed
suggests that you've got the balance
right is that really your evidence to
this parliamentary committee that's
that's not what I meant at all that was
a that was an observation as part of our
evidence that and when we spoke about
the people that were arrested to be
clear the people that were arrested in
terms of those in larger groups were
those that we believed were part of the
criminal conspiracy to disrupt the
procession
those that were arrested if we're
talking about them are public protesters
were done at a van into Martin's Lane
which wasn't part of the where the large
crowds were so that wasn't relevant to
that at all so if I mentioned that what
in my evidence what I said was
that there was a large group of
protesters that was in Trafalgar Square
and they were at various points booed by
the crowd but that was evidence that we
were striking the balance fight we
didn't arrest any of those people they
were left there and they were able to
chant whatever they wanted about not my
king and the crowd were able to boo them
as they wanted to but that didn't lead
to any police intervention okay um I'm
glad you've clarified that because the
reason I'm asking it is
um that
um the commissioner pointed out that
celebrating crowds applauded and cheered
as arrests were made in the mail area
and I think Mr Wagner who we're going to
hear from later said that that suggested
that the Met weren't taking the human
right to protest seriously
I'm just worried about this I'm just not
I'm worried about well I'm worried about
the idea
that it's a good thing to arrest people
if the crowd don't like that no it's not
it's of the essence of our
constitutional democracy that Minority
Rights are protected or unfashionable
views are protected do you accept that
so I don't think that's what happened I
don't think that's what we're saying I
think what we were saying is this was
just an observation and I think from a
policing Duty point of view it is our
duty to enforce the law without fear or
favor whether one percent of the
population support a cause or 99 of the
population support a cause thank you
okay Alison through this I think you
just have one small question you want to
ask yes have you issued an apology to
Alice chamber as the Australian that got
arrested by mistake
so at this time there's an ongoing
complaint I'm aware of the circumstances
of Miss Chambers
um and there's an ongoing complaint
um which is going to be investigated in
the proper fashion and once that's been
done we'll consider what correspondence
we need to have with her
um can I just
I just why did it take
suspicion of being equipped to lock on
to be released so you see it does seem
like
um a long time the
process of custody is quite um rigorous
it's quite
um formulaic
in this case circumstances such as if
five of the defender five of the
suspects had um the same legal advice
there would need to be a process of that
lawyer engaging with the individual then
going into interview then so it will be
done in sequence not in parallel where
there's a only one legal advisor what
happened yes
legal advisor in that for five of them
okay that's what you're saying okay and
the other thing is I just want to ask
what Communications did you have with
Westminster city council in relation to
night Stars so quite extensive
Communications actually the on the night
at the time of the stop the
um inspector on duty at Westminster
control room spoke to the Westminster
city council local Authority liaison
officer and asked about the volunteers
organization unfortunately the council
officer we spoke to couldn't confirm
knowledge of that organization although
that didn't that didn't mean it didn't
exist he was at pains to say that he
didn't the person didn't know about it
the Met gold Commander spoke to the
council gold on 6th 7th and 8th of May
and also with the chief executive across
the days the Mets neighborhood
superintendent also spoke with the
leader of the Council on the 6th of May
and the Met BCU Commander has been in
contact with members of the council on
the 7th of May you're telling me then
the Met didn't know about this
organization within London so that
operates within Westminster not not the
men the officers that were dealing with
them at the time didn't and the council
local council local Authority liaison
officer who was called out of hours he
didn't know he didn't know but he that
didn't mean that they didn't exist it
just clearly they existed didn't they I
just meant that he didn't need to know
about them that just meant he didn't
know
to a bit of a communication issue going
on really doesn't there about people not
knowing what other people know so I
think the officers did the best they
could we had an inspector called
Westminster city council and ask about
the group and the person we spoke to
who's the duty the Asian officer didn't
know so
um some lessons of communication for
Westminster city council and for the
Metropolitan and we always learn from
these things okay can I thank you very
much indeed for coming along this
morning and giving your evidence I also
want to say one other thing which is
um we take very seriously that
Parliament should be open to members of
the public that's very important but we
also take very seriously that we should
not be disrupted from our job of
scrutinizing particularly what happened
in this case I also just want to thank
the security and the police officers who
acted very quickly to ensure that the
session could continue but again thank
you very much for your time this morning
second panel
James
very much for um patiently waiting for
the panel to start as you know we are
rather restricted on time so again if I
could just say if people could answer
briefly that would be very helpful and
if members of the committee could be
brief in their questioning as well that
would be very good
um I'd like to start by asking each of
our panel members just to introduce
themselves and explain uh why they're
here today so um Graeme would you like
to start yeah I'm Graham Smith I'm CEO
of Republic and one of the eight people
not six who were arrested from the
public on May 6 without any lawful
justification thank you
Adam Wagner and I'm a barrister at douty
Street Chambers and I am an expert in
protest law thank you I'm Susie Melvin
I'm one of the three night stars who was
arrested thank you so um what we'd like
to do really is to start just actually
by asking Graham and and Susie if you
could just explain what what actually
happened and if you could just tell your
story to us we appreciate that you've
obviously been through a difficult and
traumatic experience so please just take
your time we just want to hear how what
what happened to you
thank you and I I appreciate those last
comments because I some some people have
tried to downplay the arrest and
Detention of people as an inconvenience
it is a traumatic experience for people
and should be taken very very seriously
we had I had I had written to the
commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
in January we had two meetings with
senior officers on the 8th of February
and 24th of March as well as a number of
phone call conversations and email
exchanges with a junior officer who is
our dedicated liaison officer we had
been abundantly clear with them right
the way through the process exactly what
we were planning to do we told them how
many placards we would have and what
they would say on them we told them that
we would have these large flags that you
would have seen in the footage we told
them that we would have amplifiers for
the purposes of making speeches to the
crowd we told them we would have
megaphones we gave them a map which
showed them where we would have the main
protest and that there would be other
smaller protests on the mall and on
Whitehall we gave them every piece of
information we possibly could it's
possible that the occasional tiny
minutia might have slipped through and
not been communicated but they were very
clear with us that they did not have a
single concern about any of the things
which we told them we were going to do
when we told them for example that we
had these three meter Flags they said
that they would be concerned that they
might fall into the Parade route and so
we made it abundantly clear that we
would be keeping them back well away
from the parade route towards the back
of the crowd
so at all stages and it should be
obviously noted that we have under no
obligation whatsoever to communicate
with the police it's a static protest
which does not require permission but we
have we were concerned by an arrest that
occurred in 2011 on the day of William
and Kate's wedding and arrests that
happen uh and threats of arrests that
happened immediately after the death of
the queen so we were Keen to engage and
we gave them every possible cooperation
and involvement and during that time we
had protests in five other cities or
four other cities and London in which
were peaceful where we engaged with
liaison officers where they those
officers were professional and helpful
and we never had any intention of doing
anything which even came close to
Falling outside of the law and the claim
that they had intelligence could not
possibly be true either they're being
dishonest or they are making a very
serious error because it
you cannot have intelligence relating to
a public because there was not a single
email text message WhatsApp message
conversation fleeting remark or anything
that would suggest at all that we had
any intention of doing anything unlawful
or disruptive
um we were also told because we said to
them in these meetings
would you obviously make sure that
everybody on the ground understands what
we're doing and they said yes and that
people including the bronze commanders
had been fully briefed as to what was
going on so on the day we had stayed the
previous two nights in the hotel on St
Martin's Lane we went down to Trafalgar
Square at six o'clock in the morning
with a number of pieces of equipment
including our flags and amplification
equipment
we were immediately approached by a
number of officers including the bronze
commander who seemed um not being
helpful but seeing it seemed quite
hostile and seemed to give the
impression that he didn't know what who
we were what we were doing and what our
intentions were and they
um were being I actually texted them a
message to the liaison officer saying
the officers are being somewhat
difficult I then went up the road to
meet my colleague who was driving the
van down from North London with the
placards he was having some difficulty
navigating so I jumped in the van with
him and we parked up on St Martin's Lane
we opened the back of the door and
immediately we were surrounded by large
numbers of tactical support group
officers who were not in remotely
friendly or helpful mindset they
immediately told us to stop what we were
doing I attempted to phone the liaison
officer and he told me that he was
therefore detaining me and did not allow
me to do that I attempted again and he
seized my wrist and removed my phone
from my hand and again told me I could
not do that that I told him that we had
had these meetings with a superintendent
and silver Commander I he said what was
the name of that person I told him he
clearly recognized that name and he said
that did not matter
um I repeated that we had had these
meetings as did a colleague of mine also
repeat that
um they obviously had no reason to
believe that we had anything on the ban
uh other than the placards
um which is not an offense obviously
it's not an offensive part of an unload
placards we had two large trolleys which
we had hired and the straps were there
to strap the large bundles of placards
to the trolleys so that we could quickly
and efficiently with minimal disruption
get them down onto Trafalgar Square the
straps would have gone back into the van
the van was then going to be driven back
to North London and left there for the
duration of the day in your extensive
discussions with the police had you
mentioned the the straps no because we
hadn't realized until we had them
delivered a few days earlier that they
were quite cumbersome to move so we um I
simply went on Amazon found the first
straps I saw uh picked them mainly
because they were yellow which matched
everything else we were occurring
um and uh and threw them in the van
still in the packaging so um and they
are not physically capable
um as our solicitor pointed out when she
arrived at the station and as they I
believe have now accepted that they were
not physically capable of locking people
on they may have the um uh combination
lock but they also have an adjuster like
any bag strap and they're quite long
they're also very easy to cut so they're
not particularly heavy duty they are the
sort of strap you might strap around
your case if you're going into an
airport
is there anything else you want to tell
us at this point we will want to ask you
some further questions of course um
we're only that um I I'm very concerned
by the statements that have been made
today by the police and in the letter
that they sent to City Khan there's a
lot of uh claims there which are simply
untrue
um and um I'm concerned by the
suggestion that we were there for 16
hours partly because of processing I
know uh the officer told me at 1 pm in
the afternoon that he was ready to
interview me and after that I could go I
was then told just a couple of days ago
that our semester arrived around 1pm it
was 6 p.m before I was interviewed and I
was the first of our eight to be
interviewed the first of the sixth in
that station so I would really like to
uh I would hope this committee can get
answers as to whether there was
political interference who made what
decision
um and whether this is premeditated
because it certainly had the impression
that they had turned up with the
intention of detaining us and I would
also just very quickly I appreciate um
time the notion that we were still able
to protest we weren't we were in South
but the protest was significantly
disrupted and diminished as a result of
their actions they continued throughout
the day They confiscated our amplifiers
even though they had said that we were
allowed to use them they threatened the
rest of the people with megaphones and
then arrested two people with megaphones
um and I do know for a fact that large
numbers of people then went left or
didn't turn up because of those arrests
right okay
um
just want to ask you a very quick
question clearly and you heard the
police have used the luggage straps as
the justification for detaining you and
arresting you but you described their
large numbers of police arriving and
swarming around and at that stage had
anyone seen the luggage straps or were
they still inside the van they were
still inside the van they were they
stopped us
um and detained us for searching before
they'd seen any luggage trucks thank you
all right thank you Susie would you just
explain what happened in your case uh
yep so um we commenced the night star
shift at 7 pm on Friday the 5th of May
and as part of the night Stars we Patrol
various areas including Soho Leicester
Square the embankments and so we were
walking around myself and my colleagues
with our rucksacks
um high visibility rests and the
rucksacks which contain things like
bottoms of water sick bags slippers
lollipops hair bands ponchos anything
you'd need at the end of a night out
really
um and as we were walking around we were
speaking to members of the police forces
as we always do when we're
um on patrol
um most of the night it was quite quiet
compared to a normal Friday night
um so we're mainly giving directions to
people from outside of London um as to
where they could go to watch the
coronation
um so we'd gone back to
um Saint Anne's Church which is where we
based ourselves out of and had some
dinner and myself and my two colleagues
I was arrested with we'd made the
decision that because it was quite a
quiet night we'd do a final circuit
around Soho which is generally the
busiest area and then we would go home
um so we started walking towards Soho
and Soho square is always the last area
that we would Patrol because there's
often people waiting for taxis on their
own there and a large part of our role
is trying to keep people safe
particularly towards the end of a night
out so if we see people who are on their
own waiting for an Uber say We'll offer
to wait with them so that they can feel
safer and they're not at risk of sort of
incurring any crime
um so as we're entering the north side
of sohei square we were approached by a
number of tsg Vans
um and then a large number of officers
got out of Vans and they approached us
and said that they were going to stop
and search us
so we were kept separate and the
officers looked through our bags checked
our pockets we explained to them who the
night stars were showed them emails from
Westminster city council and showed them
the night Stars website we gave them
leaflets which had been printed by
Westminster city council our high
visibility vests which do display them
at police logo as well because we're in
partnership with them at police have a
QR code on them which links back to the
Westminster CC Council website as well
sorry to interrupt you did you say then
you're in Partnership you work in
partnership with the Metropolitan Police
yes
hey right sorry sorry to interrupt no
problems um so we we did the best that
we could to try and explain who we were
to the officers
um and then they also searched the
church that we um base ourselves out of
um and we were then taken in police vans
to we were totally going to be arrested
and taken in policemans to Woolworth
um police station
um where we were held I was interviewed
at approximately one o'clock in the
afternoon the following day and then we
would release a little bit after four
o'clock on Saturday the 6th of May
goodness that's such a long time for you
to be detained yes it was yeah
right okay I'm a bit speechless actually
having heard that account
of what happened to you
your colleagues
right okay well thank you both for for
setting out so clearly what happened
that's very helpful to the committee
um we're going to have some questions so
uh lee lee understand
my question is uh for Grail thank you
for coming on the ground today now after
your arrest and the time spent in the
sales like my inbox sort of exploded a
little bit and people were saying that
it was right that it was that he was
arrested uh you described as a troubled
causer
um a public nuisance and he's just there
to ruin people's data days out that's
their words not mine
um I've looked at your website and it
says
that you Embrace democracy
so I guess my question I've only got a
question for you is if you Embrace
democracy so much
why don't you put your placards away and
stand pre-election
I don't know that that's particularly
relevant to the inquiry I think we're
interested in what happened to you on
that day and whether the law was
appropriately happy to see her and tell
you all about why the monarchy is a bad
thing and why we should be a republic
but I think we are actually focused okay
we haven't got time to go into all of
that today I'm sure we would like to
perhaps have that discussion early
that's my question right thank you very
much okay we're going to go to Alison
the Euless next thank you very much
chair I I wanted to ask Adam Wagner can
you tell me do you think the public
order act will have a chilling effect on
Peaceful process protest and if so why
well I mean you've already heard the
evidence that it is having a chilling
effect on Peaceful process it's only
been in it's only been enforced for
about 10 days
um you heard evidence from Mr Smith that
people didn't turn up and they um from
from their protest which sounds like it
would have been an entirely lawful
protest
um I'm I'm really concerned that it will
have a chilling effect
um I think the main reason is that
you've got these incred extremely wide
offenses and widely drawn offenses
particularly
um Coming equipped for looking on and
which as I think you've pointed out
could include sellotape duct tape a lock
luggage you know straps and there's it's
almost you know anything you can imagine
really that could be used to lock on
um but that's that's not that's only the
beginning of the powers because that's a
Gateway offense in the within the scheme
of the ACT which allows police first of
all to arrest and detain if they have
reasonable belief and offense is going
to be committed but also to impose um
suspicionless search
um areas so this is a that's been taken
from violent crime and gang type
behavior and they're imposing it on on
peaceful protest so what that means is
an officer who has reasonable grounds to
believe for example amongst other things
locking on offenses are going to be
committed and bearing in mind that look
the you've heard the paraphernalia of
that can be used for looking on happens
to be the same as the paraphernalia
people bring to protests to tie together
signs and what have you so you could
include any particular protest they can
then search people without suspicion in
that area for up to 24 hours they can
also impose serious
um serious disorder prevention orders
with serious disruption prevention
orders which will then prevent
potentially prevent people from entering
areas and then lead to criminal um and
to prison if they don't and all of that
picture that package for your average
person so not your sort of Hardcore
protester who's willing to risk arrest
and prison and you know full respect
people who the conscient the sort of uh
those people who are willing to put
their beliefs on the line in that way
but the vast majority of people who turn
up to protest are not those people they
are people who are going to be thinking
well I don't want to be the um Susie I
don't want to be um who wasn't even
there for the protest it was there for
something else I don't want to be caught
in the Dragnet of this public order act
I I you know I believe in this cause but
I'm not willing to risk my job risk uh
you know being in the newspapers as a
radical protester because I've been
arrested
um or detained no smoke without fire and
all that so I think you will see first
of all the chilling effect but second of
all a radicalization of the people who
end up protesting which is a kind of it
will end up being a self-fulfilling
prophecy in a way
I'm quite interested as an MP from
Scotland that maybe people coming from
Scotland down to London to protest
against the various measures uh that
happened at this place might not make
that trip because they they see that as
a risk not being able to get their train
back or not being able to uh to get back
home in good time because they're
putting themselves in the targets of
this incredibly wide law and I can
entirely understand why they would be
really worried
um because being detained and I think
that the point gray made at the very
beginning is very important I act for
lots of people have been detained by
police with calls without cause it's an
extremely traumatic experience you heard
Graham say had his phone taken off him
and that others had their phones taken
off them as well these are really sort
of oppressive potential Powers they're
necessary to prevent crime but you know
that why would you risk that it turns
peaceful protest into something which is
meant you know a really important part
of democracy democracy to something
which is a real sort of personal risk
thank you um Joanna cherry
um Adam
um can I ask you you heard the evidence
the questions I asked the police
officers about balancing
um the right to peaceful protest with
the need to protect those who might be
impacted by such a protest do you think
the Metropolitan Police well can you
tell us a bit what you think the balance
should be as a matter of Law and can you
tell us whether you think the Met police
got the bounce right the day of the
coronation as a matter of law as a
matter of human rights law I think the
balance should be very clearly
um
uh on the basis that peaceful protest is
permitted
um unless it's likely to lead to
violence
um and there may be some wriggle room
around that where you have for example
blocking the highway
um committing criminal offenses
um but in a Democratic Society
protesters very important way of
communicating people citizens
communicating with the people in power
and that should be preserved
I think the problem with this with the
public order and also the police and
crime Act is they whether you describe
it as a balance or a um or a you know a
human rights at the top of the hierarchy
or however you sort of conceptualize it
undoubtedly these this legislation is
changing the balance because what it
does is it turns something which used to
be part of the accepted impact
collateral impact of a protest which is
disruption into a crime
and once you do that you make it it
makes it seem like
um political protests and particular and
for example political protests which a
lot of protest is is itself
um a a bad thing for society um and I
think the problem with that is in a
Democratic Society political peaceful
political protest in human rights law
but also in our British tradition
is a political issue it's a matter for
politicians and what these what does
legislation does is it turns it very
much into a police issue and a public
public order issue so while with the
greatest respect to to Matt twist and
the Metropolitan Police who will
probably who will try to deal with that
balance if the scales are being tipped
as they are by this legislation it's
going to be very very difficult for them
to achieve right balance in a democracy
um just looking at the excellent the
evidence that Susie and Graham have
given us I mean I'm qualified in law
north of the Border you're qualified to
the law South of the Border
um in Scotland
um we have a concept of wrongful arrest
and a rest where there aren't proper
grounds for it or where
um some of these human rights have been
breached people can
um super wrongful arrest company and uh
seek damages for the trauma and of being
locked up for hours on end when there
was no good reason for it is it the same
in England I mean yeah I mean it would
also be a false imprisonment
um or unlawful detention so um if if
there was no reasonable grounds for
arrest I mean one thing that Mr twist
didn't mention is it doesn't just have
to be reasonable grounds there also has
to be necessity to arrest it's a
two-part test so you can have a
suspicion but then you have to also look
at the officer in charge has to look at
the circumstances and say well yeah I
have that suspicion but do I need to
arrest is that is it necessary to arrest
and potentially and detain this person
and you have to ask the question what I
mean it's difficult to know without
seeing the full facts of any case what
what the the legal sort of answer is but
um but yeah I mean I I suspect that
we'll see
um what the outcome of I mean I suspect
you'll see as much as Mr twist was
defending those actions I suspect there
will be some fairly Swift settlements of
those cases
thank you chair um Mr Smith can I just
preface my question to you by saying I'm
sure there are people on this committee
who fundamentally disagree with your
views and their organization and those
were fundamentally agree that is not the
point of today's questioning all of us
agreed on your right to protest your
cause the issue is the proportionality
and the policing of of that
can you tell me what you and your
organization hoped to achieve on the day
of the coronation
we were very clear in the run-up to this
that we wanted to
um essentially challenge what in our
view was not a national celebration but
a royal and state celebration which um
polls were showing you know a minority
were enthusiastic about we wanted to use
the opportunity to uh get our message
across which is that in a democracy we
should have a an election instead of a
coronation and instead of being told
it's going to be Charles we ought to
have a choice of our head of state and
we wanted to be very clear in front of
the world's cameras that we are not a
nation of royalists that whilst that
view is often projected in the media the
polling shows that the people's views
are quite nuanced and divided so we
wanted to create that debate and get
people's voices heard I appreciate that
obviously it's still a majority support
the retention of the monarchy but the
polling is very different so we would
essentially like any protest group we
wanted to be very clear about our
message and get that message out to a
wide audience do you think that actually
you were more successful in getting
publicity for your organization and your
cause
the fact that eight of your members
including you were arrested which seems
to have scored rather more headlines and
today is
seedings here than if none of you have
been arrested at all well I wouldn't say
the word successful I would say that
that is the case that we had more
coverage it wasn't a success in the
sense that we didn't aim to do that and
I would not wish uh to do that it was a
very heavy price to pay for that
coverage both in terms of the loss of
Liberty of eight of our people
um both staff and volunteers for our
whole day and all the stress that comes
with that as well as the very serious
impact on people's rights to protests I
would much rather that the police had
honored their assurances and allowed us
to get on with the protesters you've
just said that your aim was to get
maximum publicity for your for your
cause and your beliefs that's perfectly
reasonable but by having those eight
people arrested and subsequent what has
happened
made it impossible to ignore which is
what you wanted wasn't it
but yes but as I said it wasn't our our
objective so successful for us we were
very clear what a successful day Meant
For Us was to be able to peacefully
protest to have speeches to be near the
procession route and during that
peaceful protest to attract attention
through the national and international
media so that was successful in our mind
and that did not happen so yes by uh by
implication you know or whatever you
know as a result of those arrests we got
much more publicity but that is not
successful in our minds as a peaceful
campaign as part of those intended
activities would have made it impossible
to ignore
well the fact that we were there in
Fairly large numbers right onto the edge
of the procession and we had other
protests along the Route and by doing
that we were engaging uh with the media
who would have had a not certainly the
broadcast media would have had an
obligation to engage with the fact that
there are both protesters and also a
diversity of opinion around the issue so
yeah this is didn't happen did it
because I I can't recall any footage of
your organization protesters in
Trafalgar Square absolutely as does
everybody else recall what happened to
eight of your protesters indeed but I
and I would certainly be taking that up
with the BBC because I have a complained
to them many times their coverage of
Royal events is uh atrocious and the
fact that they didn't cover it is
something you'll have to take up with
them okay well we can all complain about
BBC in various um terms but what I'm
just interested in is on your website I
quote it says on Saturday the 6th of May
the eyes of the world will be on the
coronation I will agree with that this
is the moment we make our objection loud
visible and impossible ignore and invite
people to sign up for that so what
really was your intention doesn't
anybody reading that could get the
impression that actually there was
something rather more severe planned and
a peaceful demonstration involving a few
cards which may not be ferraged to the
place of protest by some combination
luggage straps uh no because there is
obviously we have a history of peaceful
protests we have been very clear about
what that protest would look like it was
going to be we had about 2 000 people
already telling us that they would be
there and there would be a mass in a
crowd on trafali square and if the
cameras and the BBC and everybody else
was covering it reasonably unfairly then
you would see it as part of the
coronation coverage that was our plan
now whether that would have worked I
don't know but that was the plan we are
a peaceful campaign group we always have
been
um and we have never had any intention
of causing any disruption as we have
made clear to not just the met but every
other police force where we have uh
protested so no it is not reasonable to
make any conclusions what is your
definition of disruption you've said
that you had loudspeaker equipment and
megaphones where there were the majority
of people who located themselves on the
route were there to enjoy the spectacle
the bands the music that went with it
but do not agree that if you had
somebody bellowing with the use of a
megaphone and loudspeakers things that
were contrary to what people have come
there to see that that surely is
disruptive for the many hundreds of
thousands of people who come there to
enjoy practical and the music and
everything to go with it well arguably
yes but I mean the point is that there
are people there who were
um there to demonstrate their support
for the monarchy and there were people
there that were demonstrating their
opposition to the monarchy and both had
equal rights to be there and there were
far more of them so therefore the noise
for them would be louder than us there
were more of them so they would be more
visible there was plenty of space where
people could watch the procession
without us why is it necessary to have
mega fans and loudspeaker equipment if
it was not intended to be disruptive
the disruption that we're talking about
in the context of this discussion is the
sort of disruption of locking on getting
into the route and that sort of thing if
we can if we talk about disruption in
terms of uh diminishing their PR that's
a whole different matter yes it's a
megaphone and use of loudspeakers where
people are there to listen and take in
the spectacle not by your own definition
disruptive which is what actually you
intended to be
well obviously protest wants to be uh is
it disruptive or not Mr Smith it's
disruptive only in the sense that it
disrupting the the pr aspect of the of
the parade you know it's about hundreds
of thousands of people who come there to
enjoy the spectacle and listen to the
music and various other thousands of
people in the use of a megaphone and
loudspeakers who drown over that noise
is by your own definition disruptive
which is what your intention was was it
not we raised these with matters with
the police and they were very clear that
it did not breach the law simply because
we could not physically disrupt the
piece because they there were many more
of them than there were of us so even
with amplification they had no concerns
with it and I should say again they were
abundantly clear that they had
absolutely no concerns about any of our
plans whatsoever right up until Friday
the 5th of May right so you know these
are not disruptive in the sense that
you're trying to suggest
okay thank you Carolyn Harris thank you
chair Adam
um as a politician I've been known to
protest
I've been out there on Parliament square
with a whole load of menopausal women
and we've had our say and we've had a
we've had an opportunity to vent how
we're feeling
do you think what happened on that day
is going to stop that kind of passive if
you like protest and it's going to see
for aggressive protesting that people
will be afraid people like me who don't
want to get into trouble with the police
will be afraid to have Jose and the door
will be open to more aggressive
protesting
I I think this language is really
interesting disruption that Mr Mr
lauten's been talking about aggressive
protests passive protest
protest is about getting yourself heard
um by particularly by people in power
but also by your fellow citizens and I
think that in a way the perfect protest
movement is a mass protest movement
where you've got in lots of people who
agree because you've convinced them that
that is the right the right method of
well to the right idea
and the problem
these laws are really focusing in on
those Mass protest movements and they're
making them a lot more difficult to
organize and I think the the the Genesis
of the powers in the public order bill
came originally after Extinction
Rebellion they weren't a response to
insulate Britain and sort of Road
blockages they were about the mass
protests and Extinction Rebellion which
were you know the most part peaceful and
creative and engaging they engage people
with the ideas they were very political
politically focused
and I think that they we we should be
encouraging that in society and and one
of the reasons is we want new ideas it's
really important but the other reason is
is it's always seen I think a good
democracy understands that protesters is
at the release of a safety valve
um it's a safety it's a release of
pressure to allow people to go out and
say this is what this is what I feel and
this is important to me and to do it in
a way which is a bargain and in the case
law in the courts they talk about
um Civil Disobedience and the bargain
um between the society and the
individuals
and I'm it's it's worrying that you hear
Mr loudon's questions for me but we're
quite sort of almost quite Sinister and
I'm not I don't mean that as a personal
point I just mean the the the the the
questioning itself as in you bring a
loud speaker to approach to it to a
coronation to a political event it's not
just everybody enjoying themselves it's
a very highly political event the
coronation of a constitutional Monarch
um in a system where people disagree and
agree with verminly with whether they
should or shouldn't be a king and and I
think the idea that you couldn't bring
that you could not bring a loud speaker
to a protest which is almost this sort
of bread and butter of mass protesters a
loudspeaker amplification is is really
worrying and I think that's the way
that's the direction of travel that you
have
politicians saying well you know you you
were just trying to disrupt things with
your loudspeaker by getting you know but
people are just enjoying themselves I
think that's really worrying I think
it's worrying for democracy and and I
think we need to we're in the early
stages of it but I think we need to sort
of just take a check now yeah Lizzy can
I come to you congratulations on the
work you do we have a similar outfit in
Toronto or Street pastors and it is so
so important the work that you do and I
thank you for that you're here has what
happened to you put you off volunteering
or will it put other people off actually
becoming involved in something that
could end up with
because of what happened to you
potential difficult circumstances
um so it hasn't put me off personally
um but I can certainly see that it would
dissuade other people from volunteering
if if there's a risk that you could be
arrested and detained in the course of
carrying out your volunteering so it
certainly is a worry and one last quick
question you have your ordeal having the
fact that you go on a regular basis
throughout your ordeal did you encounter
any police officer that you knew from
your previous
um trips out with the street Stars no um
the police officers who were sort of
dealing with us were from a separate
area from London um the areas that they
normally cover did have similar
organizations as well and I did give the
names of some of the metropolitan police
officers that I do know from the Soho
area and I don't believe that any of
them were contacted
helpful thank you
um when I moved to gems daily
I just care what time the hearing
finishes
well we have prime minister's question
time at 12 noon so we do try and finish
before then okay conscious people have
got questions they want to ask so I'll
let it run a little bit
uh Mr Wagner you're not here as a lawyer
are you here as a political activist
you're giving opinions political
opinions which you're you know calling
my colleagues Lawton Sinister is a new
one for this committee but the
um if you are here as a political
activist and you have set political
views it was up to the committee who who
um they wanted to invite them sorry I'm
going to interrupt you there James
because we invited
um Adam along because he'd worked with
the joint committee on human rights it's
a very distinguished lawyer and we
wanted to have that expertise
calling members of Poland Sinister rude
well rude I'm not going to stop you
asking your questions but I just want to
make it clear that Mr Wagner is a very
experienced and expert in the field of
human rights law and that's why we got
him here today
assaulting people well nobody's
insulting anybody in this room so let's
be clear about that and we're not making
this personal we're looking at the facts
of what happened and we're trying to get
to the point where we understand
decisions and why they were made so
perhaps if we do it on that level James
um Mr Smith
um so can I can I just respond to that I
didn't mean at all and I said it wasn't
personal I just found that the the idea
that you question a the head of a
protest movement for bringing a
loudspeaker um I think it's a sign of
something really difficult and dangerous
in our democracy that were that were
sort of it
I thought the question he was Sinister
I'm sorry I didn't think it was
Mr Smith
um we
um one of the concerns I have I have in
respect of this hearing is that we and
this was has been raised before is we
appear to be having a discussion
regarding a set of circumstances where
where some of the people involved in
this are not here so you've given your
take you've you've accused people of
being dishonest and various other things
there is no way of me testing that
evidence here because the police
officers who were present who arrested
you have not been invited before this
committee are not able to give their
side of the story so you know I I don't
know really know what I can ask in
respect to that because as far as I can
see
that from the information that we have
you came down here to protest and the
police officers appear to have taken a
view in respect or based upon
intelligence and on respect of
some of the items that were either close
to you or or in your possession and
possession of the other people who are
arrested that they had legal grounds to
arrest you
I mean that's basically all we can
establish isn't it you dispute that they
say they did have legal grounds and
that's that isn't it that's that's
basically the height of what we bought
we're into a very difficult set of
circumstances there well I don't think
that's the case I mean you're more than
welcome to invite the 50 members of the
Strategic tactical support group
absolutely well that's entirely up to
the chair of the committee but I would
just interrupting you they just make it
clear that when we contacted the
Metropolitan Police we did ask I think
James you'd requested this that we had
officers who were on the front line that
day who could come and give evidence or
not give evidence explain what happened
and the Metropolitan Police took the
decision that they would send assistant
commissioner twist that was their
decision and then so that's why we're in
the position we are today just so
everyone's clear
and I think it's perfectly reasonable as
someone who was detained for 16 hours
without any intent or motive even to
commit any crime
um to say quite clearly and to express
also the view of my solicitor who said
this quite clearly to the um the offices
in the station and the pace officer this
was an unlawful arrest and detention
um I mean the motive is also an
important point which I did point out to
them and which we pointed out to the
officers we had liaison meetings with
because I was at strange to or at pains
to stress so that we had no intention
whatsoever of doing anything such as in
these specific things were talked about
locking on throwing anything into the
root getting into the route or anything
else which would cause them any concern
and we were very clear that we did not
want to cause the police any concern
which is one of the reasons why we were
liaising with them and I said the aside
from anything else we do not have any
motivation whatsoever to do that because
it would be an incredibly stupid thing
for the monarchist anti-monachist
campaign to do because I fully accepted
we don't have a majority on side and I
fully accept that our job is to present
both our case and ourselves as
reasonable uh uh people who with the
reasonable message and you will not
necessarily do that uh disrupting the
coronation so you know the I think that
the the set of circumstances that were
in play at the time and I think that the
police were put in a position
where they were protecting and looking
to protect the safety of hundreds of
thousands of people
together with horses and other people
involved in the in the coronation it is
curious to me Mr Smith that you never
once mention your concern or the the
issue of the public protection of
hundreds of thousands of people
as a an important factor in what's going
through your intention when you're going
there we had discussions about that with
the police we said that we we did our
own risk assessments we took advice we
took decisions in relation to what we
were doing and how we were doing it we
had our own volunteer welfare officer
recruited we had other people
specifically to manage and hold the
large Flags uh we were very clear about
um our impact on the people around us we
have had protests in other cities where
we have engaged with the people around
us in good humor and we have made it
very clear that we're not protesting
against them
um but we are protesting against uh the
monarchy so you know it is just going on
for a month it's only what it is
specifically in the public order Act
that you disagree with that you dispute
that you think is not needed in response
to the concerns of the constituents I
represent and all of my colleagues I
think if there is a law that allows
people to be rounded up without evidence
and yeah
it's not wrong excuse me we always
representing correct what you've just
said 100 well you might want to talk to
the young woman from Australia who was
round up without evidence and ask her
about that because she spent it knows
that if there's a certain circumstances
away I was a criminal lawyer Mr Smith
for 17 years I've dealt with like Mr
Wagner with many many cases of unlawful
arrests you are pretty you are creating
the impression this is some unique
situation this is a situation that it
happens every single day throughout the
country in every police force unlawful
arrest well I think absolutely the
circumstances
okay one at a time and I think um if you
want to respond to that and then I'm
going to take mark alongi
yeah
I mean I can just reiterate there was
not a single piece of evidence of any
intent or capacity to commit any crime
when they detained us for searching and
they then released a statement saying
we'd been arrested and the conspiracy to
cause a public nuisance which was not
correct they then later rearrested me
for that in order to make my arrest uh
record match the Press statement it had
all the Hallmarks of being predetermined
and as I said
you know they tried to be as helpful as
possible
many other protests where they have been
very helpful where we have discussed
things what they could have done on that
day and this is important Point as a
contrast one after good
to the liaison officer they could have
if they said look do you mind if we look
in the van who said absolutely of course
go
as we did what they were for
they would have been put back in the van
and the van was going back to North
London and we could have carried on our
way but instead they detained us They
removed They confiscated the placards
and then continued to disrupt and
diminish the protest all the way through
the day right okay I don't accept that
for a second and I that's completely
contradicted by the evidence of the
police
say things which there is no possibility
whereby and the evidential basis that we
can challenge in this room and therefore
I I don't know why why well we're not a
court of law we're just invited people
to give their accounts and we're not a
court of law James right um Marco longy
thank you madam chair
um if I could first start with Miss
Melvin and then perhaps Mr Smith
um can I also thank you for the work
that you do and
it does appear to be very unfortunate
what happened to you
um it would it be in your judgment that
the police given the extremely high
stakes and the very high tension of the
situation on the day simply made a
mistake or do you believe there might
have been some sort of malicious element
to their actions
um a a fully accepted as a
we I was informed by the officer who
arrested me that they were specifically
looking for the night stars and
so hey Square so then found us
um which would suggest that there was
some intelligence that they'd received
that we were involved in do you think
maybe the intelligence might be around
the fact that giving out rape alarms
the fact that these devices can cause
very high pitched noises could have
caused a a sudden uh occurrence to
happen amongst the horses that were
parading and therefore potentially an
incredible amount of harm to people and
that perhaps the judgment
by police officers on the day being
risk-based had to take a view which was
unenviable
um and and the thought that the stakes
were just simply too high in retrospect
it seemed like they made that clearly
perhaps the wrong judgment but there
wasn't any malicious intent in doing so
um so we do carry rape alarms which are
part of a larger anti-spiking kit
um neither myself or one of my
colleagues have ever handed out a rape
alarm I think across the three of us we
had potentially
three four rape alums on us over the
three of us so I believe in searching
our bags and then talking to us I'm not
sure why we were then arrested and
detained
as I said there's a potential of a
mistake having taken place yes but there
was no malicious intent in doing so
Mr Smith you've made a big
the fact that you engaged a lot with the
police and I clearly commend you for for
doing so but would you also accept that
it is a well-known
uh describe an intent uh with a view to
perhaps misleading and therefore this is
something that uh the policing
authorities again having to take a
risk-based approach have to consider
whether that position is entirely
correct you have seen today that people
came in wearing a particular clothing uh
the intention was to sit behind
Witnesses and to Simply observe
proceedings but actually what they did
was completely different
um to so so they themselves
um and I'm not wanting you to compare
you clearly to just stop oil but that
policing authorities have to also take a
view a risk-based view which is whatever
is being set to them might not be
entirely be the case because there could
be even intent to mislead in order to
achieve their outcomes well indeed
obviously but I think that the um the
point with us is that we had been
speaking to them for four months and
they had made it abundantly clear that
they had no concerns even on the I think
the Thursday or the Friday beforehand
they issued a statement because there
was some concern around other statements
to be made about having low uh tolerance
protests they issued another statement
saying or they were quoted in the
telegraph I think it was saying that
they would engage with us and allow us
to continue with our protest
um and it's been pointed out by the
police officers and I think um elsewhere
that you know they would also it's not
good enough to Simply see someone in
possession of something which may or may
not be a lock-on device they need
evidence of or reasonable grounds for
suspicion of intent which they couldn't
possibly have had because there was
nothing in anything we had done said or
thought or communicated that would
suggest such intent and as I said it's
also about a proportion as I just
described they could have simply had a
conversation with us now their hostile
tone from the moment they turn up
um we made it very clear that they were
not interested in any such discussions I
mean they as I said before I immediately
said we have had these conversations I
named the superintendent we've met in
person I named the liaison officer and
attempted to phone her and he twice
stopped me from doing that including
grabbing my wrist and removing my phone
from my hand so there was no engagement
at all I mean he I as I understand it
from the letter I believe and I think
was said before that the resting officer
spoke to the bronze commander and I also
know that the bonds Commander wasn't was
engaged and briefed and all the rest of
it so yes it may happen but if we are
going to have it so broad that we just
say well these things may theoretically
happen there before we we can arrest you
because you have something which may
theoretically be used lock on and I've
turned up today with five lock-on
devices on my person you know my time I
watch my Belgium two shoelaces
um now you know someone could have
phoned up the mess and said well he's
planning to lock himself to the to the
chair when he's during the middle of the
committee and should I spend 16 hours in
detention for that so-called
intelligence and those so-called lock-on
devices I mean there has to be quite as
serious with respect I'm sorry to
interrupt because I'm very mindful of
time you can't really make such flippant
comparisons given as I described just a
few moments ago to miss Melvin that the
events of the day were clearly extremely
high stakes extremely tense for all
sorts of different reasons and that if a
police officer is given Reasonable Doubt
and suspicion that something perhaps
untoward Could Happen okay in that
particular context which may be on a
different day with a different context
might be interpretedly differently they
perhaps had no choice but to take the
actions they took I think that I think
the the Marco I don't think we need to
rehearse this again I think this
obviously but the response I received
before about shoelaces with greatest
respect Madam chair is a flippant
response to a valid point I was what I
would say is we repeat the fact that you
know there were many many things he
could have done short of the
heavy-handed arrest of uh me and my
colleagues right Simon um fell thank you
chair I'm going to be incredibly brief
because I'm very aware of time I just
want to get a couple of facts on the
record so Mr Smith your dialogue with
the Met ahead of
um the coronation
um I'm just Keen to understand the level
of detail you got into them
um over your plan so
um for instance did you tell them that
there would be straps in the back of the
van that there might be combination
locks in there that you'll be driving a
I'm assuming a Transit van into Central
London and unloading on the day was that
all in that dialogue
but I think some of the small main issue
of the logistics might have not been
communicated with them because we we'd
already established a pretty good
relationship and they knew that we were
going to be transporting 600 we told
them 600 placards would be transported
so I I don't know whether it needed to
be spelled either with they'd need a van
for that but um and the luggage strap
thing was very late in the day because
we only had delivery of the placards
very late in the day and we realized
that you know keep them on the trolleys
we would need to strap them on
um I mean they they did say to us and
the other police forces have said to us
that you know the reason why they like
this dialogue is so they don't have any
surprises on the day but you know they
it shouldn't be that difficult to Simply
engage on the day and continue that
dialogue people talk about you know
short time frames there's four hours
between us turning up and being arrested
and the procession we were well away
from the procession route it would have
been very easy to have a continued
dialogue to speak again to the liaison
team and then if they needed to just
take the straps offers and I appreciate
that but you know we were all here as
they were setting up the days before and
you know we saw the amount of effort
going into to clearing paths and making
sure everything was prepared in advance
and what I'm trying to understand is you
know were the Met police expecting a
Transit van to drive into Central and
start unloading on the morning or not
was that the sort of conversation you
were having with them
I believe so yeah but I mean again I
mean it wasn't in the controlled area
there were other vans on the same street
as well as taxes so it was within the
normal sort of Public Access area where
the van was
um and they certainly knew that we'd be
turning up with 600 placards so I'd
whether I needed to sort of tell them
the uh the nature of the van that would
be required for that I can't really
recall but um yeah I think that they
would have known that we would have been
descending on the Square in good order
with quite early on we did tell them we
would be there at 6am
um and uh we were quite clear about what
equipment we would be bringing down
there um and as I said the straps were
there to minimize disruption and
Disorder so that they would stay on the
trolley we could move them as quickly as
possible would you be prepared to share
the respondents you have with the met in
advance of this
uh yes I've got emails from uh between
myself and the
um
uh the
liaison officer um I don't see any
particular reason why you shouldn't see
them
very much and miss Melvin just
um head of
um obviously incident that happened to
you did you have any dialogue with the
Met police around you know the incoming
legislation what it might mean for you
and your operations and and how you
need to engage with them in the future
not directly no um but I'm aware that
members of Westminster city council were
in regular dialogue with the Met police
and particularly around in the lead up
to the coronation event as well and they
weren't made aware of any suggestion
that we might be involved in any sort of
plots to disrupt the coronation
thank you thank you could I just ask one
question about the letter of the 27th of
April which was sent setting out the
incoming legislation have you ever
received a letter like that before
setting out changes yes sorry
no never I mean I was quite staggered I
mean it to me and I know the officers
before said that this is not unusual but
we've never had any kind of
communication from the home office at
all and it struck me as a home office
interceding into a relationship between
us and the police it seemed very odd and
inappropriate thing to do if they wanted
the police to brief us on such things
they could have done that through the
liaison officers so it was um yeah as I
was on record it seemed uh it's only it
gave the impression of being
intimidatory I mean obviously that's a
unproven application but that's
certainly how it felt Adam have you ever
come across this before that the home
office is writing out to protest groups
setting out changes in the law
no I don't think I've got a little bell
in my head about what was going on
during covert that there may have been
some sort of communication but I don't I
don't I've not seen it in a sort of
General there is a new law but this is
quite unusual because it was a major new
law that came into effect really ours
before the um before the events
um so it was it was an unusual situation
right okay uh John a cherry and then Tim
Laughton yeah I just wanted Adam to ask
you about this this notion that this
disruptive protest is in itself criminal
with the criminalization of protest
merely because it's disruptive be in
line with um the state's duties to
respect the rights that we have under
article 10 and article 11 of the echr to
freedom of expression and freedom of
assembly and if not why not well I mean
as Mr twist rightly said the right the
the right to freedom of expression is a
qualified right so it can be limited if
there is a legitimate aim the aim could
be public protecting Public Safety could
be various other things so it is a
qualified right so you can limit you can
do things like stop people protesting on
roads we've always we've had a law
against that um obstruction of the
highway for a long time but the the what
it really depends on is what you mean by
disruption
and if the threshold for disruption is
set very low and I think they might want
my concern about the current the police
Act is that it's set at a level which
includes very noisy protests um and that
really would be would include any
protest potential any successful protest
apart from a silent protest
um I think we'll find out if the um if
the courts in the UK and potentially in
Strasbourg um consider that to be an
undue restriction and a lot will be to
do with that so the Restriction can't be
in the abstract it will have to be in in
actual the way it's enforced so what
you'll see is individual cases going to
potentially to the courts and then to
potentially transfer to the European
courts of human rights to decide where
the limits where the limits of the the
correct limits of the legislation are so
I mean it I I don't know but it's it's
cons the balance is concerning to me
thank you
I'll try
um
not to be Sinister yesterday we've only
concentrated on the Republic protesters
do you think that the those who are
arrested from just stop or were treated
unfairly I don't know the individual
facts of those cases at all
I mean and it's not for me to say
whether it was fair or not it's just a
question of whether it's lawful and I
just don't know
do you think that they should have a
right to be able to do go slow
demonstrations in front of traffic
I mean it depends on the circumstances
so that there is there is case law in
the European courts of Human Rights
about go slow demonstrations where there
was a case I think um possibly in
Lithuania where there were farmers
unions who were who were driving
tractors along roads to um and blocking
traffic and I think that was found
criminal offense was found to be
unlawful criminal conviction they could
have a case for a ghostly demonstration
that wouldn't really I mean I mean
potentially there's been also there's
been quite a lot before that before the
new go slow regulations there's been
injunctions trying to prevent people
going
um slow walking off a group of just stop
oil protesters had jumped out in front
of the Royal Coach on the coronation day
where they um and then did they go slow
in front of the uh the coach would that
have been legitimate or not I mean I
can't answer for legitimacy but it
probably wouldn't have been lawful
potentially wouldn't have been lawful
because it would have been obstructing
the highway without a reasonable excuse
what you've just said is there was a
difference of magnitude in the event of
the coronation when that would not be
legitimate and potentially just stop all
protesters doing what they've been doing
again this morning that might indeed be
legitimate so the coronation wasn't
altogether different event wasn't it
I don't think it was a different event
well I don't know if any of those events
whether on Westminster Bridge or
blocking the coronation would would be
lawful or not it depends on the fact the
nation was such a magnitude effectively
that differential policing of it would
be justified that's correct isn't it
well if that was what you took from it I
don't agree and I think that's the way
the Metropolitan Police handled it and
that's what you heard from Mr twist
that's what you heard from the
commissioner saying this was a once in a
lifetime event all of that but it's also
I mean the flip side of that is it's a
Once in a Lifetime political event to
protest at so I don't know whether that
Stacks up so the honest answer is every
event should be policed
particularly to that event with its own
factors but there's no reason in
principle why the coronation will be
different to Westminster Bridge well
that's an interesting point to end on so
can can I thank all three of you
um Graham Adam and Susie I think it's
been
um you've been asked some quite um
challenging questions but I think it's
and legitimate I'm not saying they're
not legitimate but they've been
challenging but we very much appreciate
particularly growing Susie being able to
come and talk to us today and explain
what happened we we very much appreciate
that and can I wish you all well thank
you very much for your time